aldah
uh there's space here there's space over
here if you want try and make room for
your
brothers uh so welcome everyone
to this event and the
lecture uh I want
to um say that may Allah reward the
brothers who arranged the event typo and
the brothers also from
uh uh I think it's is it hble hble the
campus hon huxton campus
um and may Allah make it beneficial for
everyone
present uh the topic of the lecture
is uh the importance of
balance and so we'll be talking about
how
to maintain our identity as
Muslims in the workplace and how
important it
is so the first thing I want to mention
is that we must remember that our
purpose in this life is to worship
Allah
alone and nothing else that is our
purpose to worship Allah Asel it is not
to chase
riches or be the one with the most
material
belongings or have the highest status is
to worship Allah alone and everything
that we do must serve this main
purpose and it must not hinder it
therefore anything that hinders it is
not legislated it's not permissible and
must be abandoned and if you leave
something for the sake of
Allah then Allah will replace it with
something
better Allah subhanahu waala
says I have not created Jin the gin and
Mankind except to worship me alone I do
not want risk from them I do not want
sustenance sustenance from them
sustenance and provision and I do not
want them to feed me it is Allah who is
the one who provides for all his
creatures the all powerful the most
strong and
Al in
his explaining this verse he says when
Allah says I do not want sustenance from
them he means I do not want them to
provide for
anyone uh from amongst my
creatures or themselves I do not need
them to provide for anyone from amongst
my creatures or
themselves and Allah also says so this
verse is similar to
uh what Allah mentions in another place
where he
says he says and order your family to
pray or perform the
prayer and be patient in performing it
we do not ask you for sustenance we will
uh provide for
you and it is piety that will Triumph in
the
end commenting on this verse he says
that when Allah says we do not ask you
for
provision he he means if you pray if you
perform the prayer your provision will
come to you from places you do not know
from Avenues that you cannot imagine
as Allah
says anyone who keeps his duty to Allah
who is mindful of Allah Allah will make
a way out for
him and he will provide for for him from
Avenues that he could not imagine and
Allah
says uh
to the end of the verse and then he
mentions the verse that we started
with
and he says commenting on this verse as
well he says we do not ask you for RIS
we means that we do not burden you to to
provide for
anyone from our creatures all
yourself and we only burden you with
action meaning worship to
Allah
and he
says
that uh if a person establishes the
prayer as they should then they are more
likely to perform the other acts of
worship properly and if they are
neglectful regarding theay prayer then
they are more likely to be neglectful
regarding the other aspects of their
religion and he says we will provide for
you meaning Allah's uh statement we will
provide for you means that your
provision is is our
responsibility we will take care of it
and we will take care of the provision
of all our
creatures if we if we provide for all
our creatures in general meaning the
ones that worship Allah and those that
do not worship Allah then how about the
one that actually worships
Allah and he busies himself with
worshiping
us until the end of what he
[Music]
says
and he mentions the same thing uh he
says we do not ask you for provision
meaning we do not ask you to provide for
yourself or them meaning others and you
should occupy yourself with prayer or or
rather you should not preoccupy
yourself uh from prayer with looking for
your provision meaning don't let it keep
you from worshiping
Allah
and
Allah he says
he says blessed is he in whom H in whose
hands is everything is the Dominion of
everything and he is able to do all
things the one who created death and
life in order to test you which one of
you will be best in action so here Allah
is telling us that the reason why he
created life and death is to test us
which of us will be best in our actions
meaning our acts of
worship and so we have to understand
from these verses that the aim of
earning a
livelihood um is or rather we have to
understand that earning a livelihood is
not the aim but but a means to an end it
is a means to an end so earning a
livelihood is
important and and of the utmost
importance but it is a means to an end
indeed part of a muslim's identity is
that he fends for himself and his family
and those in his charge he tries his
best not to ask others for anything and
he makes a living to be able to fulfill
his spiritual and worldly duties not to
compete with others or look down on them
or to be greedy and so on and not to be
exalted over others but in order to keep
himself modest and from having to need
others the prophet
s.
[Music]
wasam he said
says he says the giving hand literally
the upper hand or the hand above is
better than the hand below meaning the
giving hand is better than the hand that
takes and he said the giving hand is the
hand that that spends and the the one
that takes is the hand of the one who is
asking and he
said he
said he said a person never ever ate a
morcel of food better than what he
earned with his own
hands and the prophet of Allah dud used
to eat from what he earned with his own
hands because
da was a king he was a king and despite
the fact that he was a king he used to
uh he used to uh earn a living for
himself with his own hands by making uh
armor and these kind of
things and the prophet sallallah alai
wasallam
said he said for he said it is better
for a person to carry a bundle of wood
on his back and sell
it then to ask
uh anyone for anything whether he gives
it to him or not whether he gives him
gives it to him or not and a man came to
the prophet
Sall and he
said he said tell me an action that if I
were to do it ah would love me and
people would also love me so the prophet
Sall wasallam
said
abstain in the D
meaning take what you need from the d z
z means not having an attachment in your
heart to worldly material things and he
said and leave alone what the people
have leave their possessions don't ask
them for things don't uh seek what they
what they have and the people will love
you so earning a living for the right
reasons and with the right intentions is
encouraged but it must come second to
one's Faith this is because the Muslim
identity is centered around the worship
of Allah alone first and foremost it is
centered around the Pres presence or
absence of Faith this is what our
identity is whether you have faith or
you don't have faith this is what Islam
considers your identity this is what
determines how you are treated in Islam
your identity does not depend on your
wealth your race your looks your
nationality Etc these these things are
not identity in Islam these things are
only
identities amongst the
unbelievers the prophet
sallam
said he said Allah has removed from you
the arrogance and pride of the times
before
Islam and the way they used to boast
about their fathers their forefathers
and their
ancestors people are either a Believer
who is pious or a criminal who is
wretched people are from Adam they
children of Adam and Adam is
from uh from
dust and in another narration he
said Allah has removed from you the
arrogance of the pre Islamic times and
the way they used to Pride themselves in
their ancestor
um so people are one of two types either
he is a good man who is pious and
honorable with
Allah or a wretched criminal who is
Despicable to Allah
and people are children of Adam and so
on he
says Allah does not consider your
forms your forms your physical forms or
your wealth but he considers your heart
and your
actions and so your faith is what you
need to protect first and foremost and
this is why the scholars Place Faith
first on the list of the essentials of
Life what we call
the the things that you need to live
before they play place it before life
lineage and intellect and in fact they
Place wealth as last on the
list and Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala says
criticizing the
unbelievers and
woe and woe to the
unbelievers due to a severe
[Applause]
punishment he says Those Who prefer the
life of the dun the life of this world
to the
Hereafter and they prevent others from
the path of
Allah and he
said
[Music]
those who do not hope for the meeting of
the here for our meeting meaning meeting
Allah and the Hereafter and they are
satisfied with the life of this world
and happy with it and they are heedless
of our son
those people their destination is hell
because of what they used to
earn and he
said
he
says say to them if your fathers and
your children and your brothers and your
wives and your uh tribes men or your
clansmen and wealth that you have worked
for and business a business or trade
that you fear uh a loss on and dwellings
that please you are more beloved to you
than Allah and his messenger and
striving in the path of Allah then wait
until Allah brings his
judgment and Allah does not guide those
who are those who are blatant
Sinners and
so Allah in this verse is showing us
that we have to place before all these
other things these relationships that we
have even let alone things of material
gain uh the love of Allah and the
messenger and the love of obedience to
to
Allah and Allah subhanahu waala
says
he said Those whom the Angels take their
souls whilst they are oppressing
themselves the angel said to them what
was your situation why are you in this
state meaning and they say we were
downtrodden on the earth we were weak
and they say the Angels say to them was
Allah's Earth not wide enough vast
enough for you to migrate within it
those meaning these people their
destination is hell and what an evil
destination it is so in making hij you
leave your home and your wealth behind
to protect your
faith so a person must be careful that
he is not selling his faith for material
possessions like the prophet
sallallah wasam said when he
said until the end of the verse here the
prophet Sall wasam is criticizing a
person who he he
calls he's a slave to
money a slave
TOA material thingsa is like a piece of
clothing a type of piece of clothing but
it is uh like making an analogy of
someone who's enslaved himself to
materal material wealth material gain if
he is given and if Allah gives him he is
happy and if he doesn't then he is
unhappy he is unhappy and the prophet
Sall
said literally means to fall on your
face and in this situation it means he
is may may he be disgraced may he be
disgraced and completely and
utterly
meaning may he not find relief from even
the slightest discomfort even a thorn
prick so this is a huge Dua by the
prophet sallallah alai wasallam against
this kind of person and he
said
[Music]
it says whoever makes this life his main
concern Allah will scatter his Affairs
and he will place his poverty in between
his eyes meaning that's all he can see
is that he doesn't have enough he
doesn't have enough he he sees that he's
needy no matter how much he gathers and
only what he the only thing he will get
from the dun is what was written for him
anyway and whoever makes the here after
his intention his main concern Allah
will arrange his Affairs for him he will
gather his Affairs
together organize them and he will put
his contentment in his heart even if he
has only a little bit he will be
satisfied with it and the dun will come
to him despite that despite the fact
that he doesn't pay that much attention
to it and so when you choose your means
of earning a living choose one that is
lawful in itself and in which the
environment is lawful and conducive to
your practicing your religion properly
and keeping your identity as a Muslim
you must avoid work that compromises
your identity and makes it difficult to
practice your religion or goes against
its major tenants worship of Allah alone
following the prophet Muhammad sallallah
alai wasam honor and dignity good
character performing the five daily
ritual prayers and J just Justice and
fairness celebrating the two eids
Chastity and many other virtues are all
part of the muslim's identity anything
that compromises these things should be
avoided one of the most important things
that people are LAX about when they work
is performing the five daily prayers a
lot of people pray them all together
when they get home or may end up not
praying them at all cuz when they get
home they think I have to pray four
prayers now and it's too much for them
so they end up sometimes not even
praying at all this is a grave sin
indeed this is a very grave
sin was asked about some people who
delay the prayers of the night night
meaning and till the day meaning they
don't pray them on time and they they
pray them when they're done because of
because of being preoccupied with
farming or because they're in a state of
major impurity and they can't find any
way to purify themselves or because
they're in service to a teacher or some
such thing he says is it permissible for
them this is the
question and Islam says it is not
permissible for anyone to delay the
prayers of the day until the night all
the prayers of the night until the day
because of any kind of uh um because of
being preoccupied with anything any any
kind of act he says not because of um uh
farming or because of harvesting or
because of some trade or even because of
a state of major
impurity or the fact that they have
impurity on their body he says or
because they're hunting or because of
entertainment or play or because they're
in service to anyone or anything else he
says the Muslims Muslims all Muslims
agree e that they must pray and during
the day and Before
Sunrise and they must not uh busy
themselves away from doing that with any
kind of
action he
says and it is not for a person to stop
his servant from doing the prayer at its
time
nor for any employer to stop his
employee from praying on time and
whoever does that whoever delays his
prayer because of any one of these
things that he mentioned before he said
it is obligatory to punish such such a p
a person rather he is to be given
capital punishment meaning he will be uh
in in in uh according to to most of the
scholars he is meant to be put to death
this is their judgment on this person
that he should be put to death after
after he has been called to
repent so if he if he repents and he
agrees to start praying on time then he
is left alone and if he insists that
he's not going to pray on time he's
going to delay his prayers then that
person will be put to
death and then he mentions what the
scholars say about praying even during a
battle so a lot of Scholars whilst you
whilst a person is in the midst of the
chaos of war and
fighting they still obligate him to pray
on time because time is the most
obligatory aspect of prayer nothing is
allowed to get in the way of praying on
time not any kind of of business or work
or even a state of impurity if a person
is in a state of impurity and they can't
find a way to purify themselves with
water then they do T if they can't even
find that and they pray as is they pray
as is if you're naked and you can't find
anything to clothe yourself you pray as
is if you cannot find anything to cover
yourself within the
time so this is what uh the Sheikh was
saying and the bottom line is in some
circumstances like during travel and if
you are sick and other such
circumstances it is permissible to join
between
and whether you join at the time of or
you join at the time of or and between
is and M and
is but
but no one has ever allowed a person to
pray all the prayers together under no
circumstance is it allowed for you to
pray and at the same time as many people
do this is a major sin this is a major
sin a grave sin
indeed Shaz was asked the same question
and he gave the same answer you are not
allowed to delay delay your prayers for
any reason
whatsoever he was asked he
says what is the ruling the person
asking say what is the ruling on uh
praying more than one prayer
together he said out of necessity as he
claims because the person is at work
because the person is at work the sheh
said he said praying all five prayers
together is a major sin and
whoever does that on purpose doesn't
pray on time without a valid excuse
meaning a legitimate excuse in in in uh
Islamic
law his prayer will not be accepted even
if he prays a 100 times because the
prophet sallallah alaihi wasallam said
he said whoever does an action that goes
against our Command or or that we have
not commanded the action will be
rejected be rejected it will not be
accepted and a person who delays his
prayer till it till the time for it
expires without a valid excuse then that
person without a doubt has done
something that the prophet Sall neither
Allah or his messenger has has
commanded he says so his prayer will be
rejected he
says he says praying all the five
prayers together at the same time is a
major sin in fact it is one of the worst
of the worst
sins besides sh associating partners
with Allah which is the worst of sins he
says so it's not it's not permissible
for someone to do that because of work
he should leave work meaning temporarily
and go and pray and then return to his
work after
that and then he goes on to
say I say to this person and to everyone
listening that praying establishing the
prayer is a means is a means to
attaining sustenance because sustenance
is from
Allah as Allah
says the ver that we saw
earlier I want to mention something
about necessity emergency or duress what
what does it
mean in Islam what does it what do we
mean by this what does this word mean in
Islamic law because a lot of people make
excuses for themselves and they say I
was it was a I I had to do it it was a
necessity so to speak so Scholars have
defined a
necessity uh the necessity that allows
you to do something forbidden right
allows you to do a forbidden thing
something normally forbidden allows you
to do it what is that necessity how do
we Define it most of the scholars Define
it as an existential threat meaning that
it threatens your
well-being it threatens your well-being
in a lifechanging
manner that is your faith your life your
honor your intellect or your
possessions due to this situation will
be completely
erased meaning you might die or be will
be completely harmed or damaged or
depleted for example your wealth will be
completely
depleted depending on the situation
unless one does that forbidden thing so
basically you fear death or you fear
something similar to death something
that that will um impact your life in
such a way
that it is similar to
dying okay some of the scholars say that
it is a situation in which a person will
be harmed okay a person will be harmed
and they have no recourse to any other
to anything that will repel that harm
except the Forbidden thing meaning
something's going to harm you and the
only way to avoid that harm is by doing
the Forbidden thing these are the
definitions of a according to the
scholars so many of the things you will
realize that many of of the things that
people
call are not a taking a mortgage for
example because you don't want to pay
rent is not okay because you can pay you
can pay rent as an alternative which is
halal you're not going to die if you
don't have a mortgage not going to lose
your wealth you're not going to have
anything really happen to you sure
you're going to be paying someone else's
rent but it's better than uh going to
war with Allah and his Mercy M okay so
many examples like this where people
think that it's a necessity and it's not
a necessity take note that this is the
definition of a necessity it also has
conditions okay the conditions are one
that the threat is real and not merely
imagined it's not merely imagined or
expected okay you can't you know maybe
I'm going to lose a limb or maybe this
thing will kill me perhaps perhaps I
don't know perhaps this harm will be me
will be for me you have to the the
threat has to be real okay it has to be
real or its cause must exist the very
least okay there must be no lawful
alternative there must be no lawful
alternative so if you're in the middle
of a desert and you're hungry you
haven't had nothing to eat and all you
can find is some dead meat for example
you're allowed to consume consum it but
if there is something Halal there then
you can't consume it it's not
allowed so that's the second thing
there's no lawful alternative the third
condition is that it is known that the
lawful the unlawful thing will actually
alleviate the situation okay and the
scholars make an example of a person
dying of thirst who only finds a bottle
of alcohol alcohol does not alleviate
thirst it causes thirst apparently okay
so if a person were to drink it it's not
going to alleviate their thirst anyway
so it's not permissible for them as
opposed to someone who is choking on a
piece of food and then only finds
alcohol to send the muscle down so that
they don't choke on it then that is
permissible if there's nothing else
because it's a liquid it will and may
very most likely send the muscle down so
you don't choke to death on that muscle
of food okay so it must be known to to
alleviate that
situation the fourth one is that the
unlawful thing does not threaten
something more important than the thing
we're trying to save okay so if you're
going to forgo your
religion because of your money then you
choose your religion you don't choose
your money okay or even your life or
even your life all right
[Music]
um uh and the last one is that the
unlawful thing does not transgress
against someone else okay the unlawful
thing does not transgress against
someone else and the scholars Give an
example like someone puts a gun to your
head and says kill that other guy kill
fan you're not allowed to kill that
person to save your own life life okay
it's better for you to be killed than to
go and have yourself kill someone
else okay um so hopefully that is
[Music]
understood number four was that the
unlawful thing does not threaten
something more
important than the thing that we're
trying to save doesn't threaten
something more important than the thing
we're trying to
save uh I want to also talk about honor
honor and protective
jealousy which
are some uh other aspects important
aspects of the Muslim
identity uh many Muslims forgo their
dignity and honor in order to earn a
living or whilst earning a living
sometimes it's not even necessary they
just do it because they want to fit in
okay sometimes the job necessitates it
but a lot of the time maybe most of the
time especially in this country for
example where they have all you know
they have all kinds of human rights laws
and all this stuff um you know you don't
have to compromise your religion or your
honor in many cases but people feel
pressured to do it to fit in because
they know that that you know there's
they believe there's stigma against
Muslims we don't want to see a certain
way so we have to fit in uh with the
non-muslims and in order to please them
and this is not correct a Muslim should
never lower himself just because he
wants to fit in sometimes for example uh
during Christmas you might go into a a
supermarket and find the Muslims wearing
Father Christmas hats I've seen this so
many times the the unbelievers are not
wearing them the non-muslims are not
wearing them the Muslim is wearing the
Hat why are you wearing the Hat why do
you feel the need to wear the hat that
the the the the the the non-muslims are
not even wearing the Hat okay so this is
this is a feeling of inferiority is a
feeling
of want wanting to Fe fit in and portray
yourself as
sympathetic towards whatever it is that
they've got going
on okay you should never do that you
should never compromise your faith
because of fear that your unbeliever
colleagues will think ill of you treat
people fairly yes give them respect when
they respect you and be merciful to
people and there's no harm and be in
being kind and fair to people who do not
persecute you for your faith as Allah he
says Allah does not prevent you or
prohibit you from being uh good and just
kind and just to those who have not
fought you due to your religion or
exiled you from your
homes Allah loves those who are
just Allah only forbids you from uh
befriending and loving and uh uh the
that kind of meaning with those who have
fought you due to your religion and
exiled you from your homes and conspired
with those who exiled you from your
homes he prohibits you from being
friendly to these kinds of people and
whoever does that whoever shows them
love gets together with them in Dearing
himself to them and those people are uh
unjust
okay but that doesn't mean that you
compromise your faith and yourself at
any chance you get so that they can like
you Allah
says can you
read whoever
wants
honor
Prestige power cloud that's what means
has that kind of
meaning strength power clout Prestige
nobility influence whoever wants these
things then all of that is belongs to
Allah alone all of is belongs to Allah
alone and Allah says about the
Hypocrites the he
says
it says they say if we return to Medina
the the the powerful ones the noble ones
the prestigious ones meaning themselves
will chase out the lowliest ones meaning
the Muslims and Allah says but is
belongs to Allah his messenger and the
Believers but the Hypocrites do not know
the Hypocrites do not
know
so low lowering a lot of people think
that lower lowering themselves and
pandering to Believers will bring them
this is the excuse anyway will bring
them into Islam but the fact of the the
matter is no one wants to join something
that is portrayed as
inferior nobody wants to join something
that is portrayed as inferior this what
many people don't understand so
retaining your honor and showing the
superiority of your faith to theirs is
how you attract people people want to
join things that are better not less
than what they have okay pandering to
them and being compliant and complacent
that strengthens their
position okay and this is one of the
reasons why imitating unbelievers is
forbidden in Islam and is a major aim of
the Shar this what Allah says when he
changed the
from to makah and he
says uh the
verse sorry I can't remember what it is
now it's in Surah Bak but basically it
means that um so that they don't have hu
against you meaning the people of the
book the people of the book don't have
any argument against you for facing
their their and them saying Oh look if
their Dean was so good why would they be
facing
our so um when you imitate them and you
Pander to them that's what they feel
they feel better than you so why would
they enter your religion why would they
enter your religion you have to have
protective jealousy for Allah's Dean
okay you can't be happy and silent and
sit with them when they mock Islam and
they insult as aspects of Allah's
religion okay this is this is a sign of
hypocrisy all right A lot of people sit
with unbelievers
whilst they Mock and revile Islam
because they want to appear Progressive
and
open-minded and Allah subhah waala
says give Tidings Glad Tidings to the
the Hypocrites that they will have a
painful
punishment
those who take the unbelievers as allies
friends besides the Believers do they
seek honor from them honor belongs to
Allah all honor belongs to Allah
alone and he
says
he has sent down to you in the book that
if you when you hear Allah's verses
being
rejected and mocked don't sit with them
until they talk about something
else otherwise you'll be like
them Allah will bundle the Hypocrites
and the unbelievers in hell
together and so it is important that we
understand these
things uh all the the so-called
Progressive and open-minded stuff is for
unbelievers who have no
certainty okay we don't need to be
open-minded open-mindedness is for
people who have doubt okay if I am sure
about my religion why do I have to be
openminded why do I have to be
open-minded you have to understand that
the unbelievers are in doubt okay they
are all in doubt they have no y
whatsoever on what they're upon no
matter how don't let the pump and the
glitter and the propaganda fool you
Allah says this is why Allah said or the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
that that when they when the unbeliever
dies and the angel questions him what
does he say when he ask him the three
questions he
says he
[Music]
says he says I don't know who is your
lord who's the man that was sent to you
what's your religion I don't know I
don't know I don't know I heard people
saying something and I said it that's
his answer because they have they're
full of Doubt so Allah says in the Quran
in many
places they only follow conjecture so
they have no certainty you on the other
hand the believer you are have certainty
in your book in the prophet that was
sent to
you so why do you have to be openminded
some of these people are not open-minded
about the food they put in their mouth
they not openminded about their diets
they want you to be open-minded about
your faith okay there's no need for that
there's no need for that and as for
being Progressive then there is nothing
more backward than kufur and there's
nothing more barbaric than disbelief in
Allah and and associating partners with
Allah worshiping idols and giving the
attributes of Allah to inanimate objects
what's Progressive about that kufur and
shik Destroy societies kufur and shik
and and sins destroy societies there's
nothing Progressive about these things
things
um is the do we need to stop or should
we carry on I know nothing okay um we're
almost done inshallah
uh I just want to mention something
quickly about working for unbelievers
okay working for
unbelievers um Imam
he mentions
in which is a book on basically the
rulings regarding the people the zies
who are they are the people under the
opes of the Islamic State okay they pay
the gizia and they get the pro
protection of the Islamic State but they
have to live under the rules of Islamic
State okay so this book is how to how we
deal with them and in it he he has a
section on working for AI working for
and is it permissible okay and to
summarize he he mentions the of
iMed to summarize it he says there are
three three ways in which a Muslim works
for a a non-muslim okay one is that he
works for him in general so he hires him
meaning the the The non-muslim Hires the
Muslim to do some work for him he said
say this is
permissible uh the second way
is that he hires you to be to do a job
that entails servitude towards him okay
he hires you to to to send you around
maybe like a like a house boy or a maid
or something like that go and get me
this go and get me that um this kind of
thing running errands kind of like a
call a like it's a servitude kind of job
and he said the most correct opinion in
the mhab at least is that it is not
permissible because it involves a a
Believer lowering themselves to a
non-believer okay and the third
one is that he uh does some some uh work
for him for him where they are sort of
Partners okay it's like a service you
provide a service to them so not working
for him per se but you provide a service
to them uh to make something for example
then this is also permissible right so
that's a summary of that he saids this
is as long as none of this involves
things that are specific to them for
example building a church for them it's
not permissible to do that or building
something specific to them anyway way or
their religion then it is not
permissible um we have to we have to all
understand that the the paths of risk of
provision of sustenance are
unrestricted okay they are not limited
to one particular path okay it's not
only one path
you have to go to this place and go and
get a degree and then go and get a job
or you have to go and get a white color
job etc etc etc there are
numerous parts of risk alhamdulillah
there are numerous ways to make a living
that are much better than that okay and
so don't limit yourself to only one way
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala created
everything in the heavens and the Earth
for the the the creatures on Earth for
human beings so how can you
limit uh sustenance to Only One path
this is
ignorance okay and there are many verses
that we can look at but time doesn't
allow and one of the greatest means of
receiving sustenance of course is
obedience to Allah so obedience to Allah
like Allah
says
he said if only the people of the book
believed and feared Allah we would have
removed their sins and would have
entered them into Gardens of Bliss it
says If Only They had upheld the T and
the injil and what was revealed to them
from their lord they would have eaten
from above them and beneath their
feet and so and there are many other
verses like that where Allah talks about
how believing in him and and making Toba
to him will increase risk it will
increase risk it doesn't remove risk
being obedient to Allah does not limit
your risk you just have to be patient
you just have to be patient with what
Allah wants for you and so we have to
put our trust in Allah subhanahu waala
put our trust in Allah because Allah
says as you
know okay whoever fears Allah Allah will
make a way out for him and provide for
him from places he does not even know
and whoever puts his chust in Allah then
Allah is enough for him okay um what's
the best way to make a living some of
the scholars say business and farming a
lot of Scholars mention business and
farming as the best ways to make a
living with some debate as to which one
is
better advises people to seek a living
and try their hands at business rather
than work in like a 9 to5 he said that
um people don't earn that much from them
whereas if you make if you do business
then you have an unlimited potential for
earnings have unlimited potential right
he said employment should be the last
option he said but start start young and
and little by little you will grow and
then you will earn uh a lot of money
you'll be able to to to earn to become
wealthy as a businessman as a
businessman he said it's better than
being employed in summary the best thing
for you is what you have an affinity for
okay what you love to do that is halal
what you have an affinity for what
you're comfortable with what you're good
at that's what you should focus on to
make a living if you can make a living
from it do that start young
alhamdulillah most of the brothers here
are young you have a lot of time
inshallah tala start early and then um
by the time you get to an age where you
have responsibilities then you you
already have enough skill to make a
decent living from what you're doing cuz
everything is a skill even business is a
skill that you have to grow you will
fail and try again and fail and try
again but the more you do it then the
better you become lastly I want to talk
about mitigating being around
unbelievers and people of sin if you
work with unbelievers for example you're
around them all
day every day they're going to rub off
on you there's no doubt they're going to
rub off on you okay the prophet
sallallah Al wasallam
said
right right the like of a a good
companion is and a bad companion is like
the perfume seller and the man who uh
works the Bellows meaning like a
blacksmith
right uh he says that the the the
perfume seller will
either um sell to you or he will give
you some for free or at the very least
you will smell something nice okay so
it's going to benefit you even in the
smallest way no matter what it's going
to benefit you whilst the other guy with
his Bellows and and all the sparks
flying is either going to burn your
clothes it's going to burn your clothes
or at the very least you're going to
smell something awful okay so they will
harm you no matter what okay you will
you will get some of their character
like Allah subhanahu waala
says
he says don't marry the until they
believe the the idol worshippers until
they believe and a slave girl who is a
Believer is better than a free woman who
is Idol worshipper even if you are
impressed by that woman meaning the mush
and don't marry your women to
mushriks okay A Slave who is a mushrik
I'm sorry who is a Believer is better
than a free man who is a a mush even if
that man may impress you um they call to
hell this is the Shah is that they call
to
Hell the the
meaning the way the things they do the
things they do the way they behave they
all um
attract you attract a person not that
they necessarily invite you to hell okay
literally invite you to to go to hell
but the the things they do the things
they do the Chara their character their
ideology all of that is an invitation to
hell it's one of the means to go to hell
that's how they that's how they are so
that will rub off on you and so to
mitigate that you need to um find
yourself again okay go to the Masid
after work if you can or go on the
weekends at least go to some lessons
increase your thck of Allah okay while
you're even at work increase your of
Allah read the Quran frequently okay
give charity charity is excellent for
purification all right hang out in your
free time with good people with your
believing Brothers your brothers from
don't go and hang out with those same
people after work okay yeah we're going
down to the pub or we're going to go to
whatever fan club or we're going to
limit limit your association with them
to to when you can't help it which is at
work okay that that is how you save
yourself from becoming like them okay
because very easy to become like these
people and in conclusion uh I ask Allah
to make us of those who seek our
sustenance responsibly and do not make
this material world our main concern
like the prophet sallallah alaihi wasam
used to
say do not make the D our biggest
concern or the limits of our knowledge
and to be of those who seek their
sustenance respons like the prophet
sallallah alai wasallam said he
said uh he
says right he
says seek your
responsibly no soul will die until it
completely consumes what has been
written from for it the sustenance that
has been written for
it even if it takes time okay so what
what Allah has written for you will come
to you so take what is halal and leave
alone what is Haram leave alone what is
Haram
um and uh
alhamd